[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue pour ce nouveau numéro
du 7-8 l'hebdo ensemble nous allons
revenir sur l'actualité de la semaine
dans les yvelines
au sommaire ce vendredi 3 juillet les
écologistes ont remporté deux grandes
villes au niveau national au terme de
ces élections dans les événements si on
observe une poussée verte
nous en discutons avec david jutier
candidat europe ecologie les verts
arrivé second à rambouillet lors des
municipales
un nouveau maire attrape met enfin à 19
ans de mandat de guy malandain la
verrière qui bascule à droite et le
rassemblement national qui perd sa seule
commune d'île de france
nous reviendrons sur ces élections
municipales dans les yvelines le
nettoyage de la décharge sauvage de
carrières sous poissy un point sur vos
vacances qui commencent ce vendredi est
le tout premier meeting d'athlétisme des
yvelines poste confinement vous
retrouverez ce qui a marqué l'actualité
dans notre département comme chaque
semaine c'est l'une des conclusions de
ces élections municipales une réelle
percée verte au niveau national des
listes écologistes ont même emporté des
villes bastions de la droite comme
annecy et bordeaux dans les yvelines
aussi les idées vertes sont imposés dans
la campagne il était rare de voir des
programmes qui ne parlait pas
d'environnement elles ont retrouvé de
nombreux candidats écologistes david
jutier vous êtes co secrétaire d'europe
écologie les verts d'ile-de-france
bonjour bonjour alors je rappelle que
vous veniez également une liste à
rambouillet et que vous êtes arrivé
second derrière véronique matillon issus
de la majorité sortante vous obtenez six
élus au conseil municipal et trois au
conseil communautaire
alors tout d'abord que retenez vous de
ces élections municipales à rambouillet
bien sûr mais aussi dans le reste du
département
globalement effectivement c'est ce que
vous disiez il ya quelques secondes on
constate une percée très importante dans
l'est dans les urnes des des idées et
des programmes écologistes c'est quelque
chose qui était attendue depuis
longtemps je pense qu'on avait déjà
gagné une forme de bataille culturelle
une grande partie de la population avait
pris conscience de l'urgence écologique
de l'urgence sociale
et puis on a su ces dernières années
construire des projets qui étaient
crédibles qui était globaux qui
qui contenait toutes les toutes les
problématiques pas uniquement purement
environnementale qui qui répondent aux
besoins des gens et la bascule est en
train de se faire entre cette prise de
conscience massive dans la population et
le vote et ça c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important parce que ça
nous permet de nous ancrer aujourd'hui
dans les territoires alors que jusqu'à
présent nous étions principalement
présent au niveau des régions au niveau
de l'europe
et cet ancrage territorial il est très
important parce qu'il va nous permettre
de prouver que concrètement localement
l'écologie réel ça fonctionne on avait
déjà quelques quelques exemples de
villes je pense à arcueil en ile de
france dans les yvelines
amnésie ou à et vêtements par exemple
évidemment la ville emblématique de
grenoble une somme apportée depuis
maintenant six ans et qui aa fait
l'administration de la pertinence de
l'écologie haut niveau au niveau local
est donc désormais c'est à nous de
montrer et de faire la preuve que
localement et à une très grande échelle
les programmes écologie fonctionne pas
simplement pour l'environnement mais
aussi pour le social pour la démocratie
pour la démocratie locale andresy pour
ces élections 2020 a un nouveau maire
écologiste aussi et s'il pourrait y en
avoir d'autres l avenir mais bien
entendu qui pourrait y en avoir d'autres
vous avez rappelé qu'à rambouillet on
est arrivé on est arrivé second avec un
très petit nombre de voix d'écart sur la
candidate de droite soutenus par gérard
larcher véronique matillon fait de très
beaux scores dans un grand nombre de
deux villes donc évidemment qu'on va
continuer à travailler les yvelines sont
une terre de droite depuis plusieurs
décennies c'est effectivement encore
long qu'un chemin c'est compliqué de
faire changer les habitudes de vote de
personnes qui depuis est très longtemps
sont habitués à voter pour la même
couleur politique même si profondément
beaucoup de personnes qui sont ancrés à
droite ont une conscience écologique
elles ont simplement pas encore fait ce
geste électoral de voter pour des listes
écologistes est ce que l'on espère c'est
que justement localement à andrésy vous
l'avais dit dans les yvelines mais à
colombes où un maire écologique
patrick schein au beach emporte la ville
nous allons faire la démonstration que
un maire écolo c'est un maire qui se
préoccupent de tous les sujets qui est
le maire de l'ensemble des habitants et
habitants de sa ville et que c'est pas
une révolution
un changement brutal nous ce que l'on
prononcé la transition écologique elle
est urgente il faut la faire rapidement
mais on l'a fait quand on est aux
responsabilités en concertation et pour
le bien du territoire donc je pense que
cette vague verte
elle va continuer à déferler au cours
des prochaines élections
pour le plus grand bien de l'ensemble
des territoires
là on les municipales social un jeu
souvent de soutien d'alliance on a vu
que europe écologie les verts soutenus
souvent des candidats de gauche je donne
l'exemple exemple la trappe avec le
soutien alliés arabes et c'est aussi une
façon d'avoir des victoires est ce que
c'est une stratégie qu'europe écologie
doit conserver pour la suite alors
d'abord je tiens à féliciter ali rabais
pour pour son très beau score et
lui souhaite évidemment une bonne prise
de fonction c'est formidable ce qui
vient de se produire à trappes où on a
vu que un maire de gauche entre guinée
avait finalement choisi un soutien de la
république en marche qui est clairement
aujourd'hui positionné plutôt à droite
et ses étiquettes ce clivage gauche
droite en fait c'est pas c'est pas ce
qui nous intéresse nous on n'est pas les
écologistes là pour reconstruire la
gauche ou pour faire battre la droite
on est là pour porter notre projet qui a
un projet écologique et un projet social
qui est un projet démocratique
donc quand on a des modes de scrutin qui
sont aussi aussi injuste on peut le dire
que les scrutins municipaux ou la liste
key qui arrive en tête rafle tout prenez
l'exemple de rambouillet véronique
matillon 47% nous 37% finalement tous
les postes vont à la liste de véronique
matignon on est évidemment obligé de
nouer des alliances et ses alliances on
line ou pas en fonction de l'étiquette
de gauche de liste avec lesquels on peut
on peu salie mais vraiment avec la
crédibilité avec le programme des
personnes et des listes avec lesquelles
on souhaite se réunit alors si j'évoque
un peu la suite le prochain scrutin
disaient les départementales est-ce que
europe écologie compte jouer un rôle
dans ces élections là les prochains
scrutins ce sont les départementales et
les régionales qui vont avoir lieu le 31
mars prochain
ensemble évidemment europe ecologie les
verts et d'une manière générale tous les
tous les écologistes ont un rôle
déterminant à jouer danser dans ces
élections parce que les départements
c'est avant tout l'action l'action
sociale et évidemment nous sommes très
attachés à la solidarité et au social
qui figure en bonne place dans tous nos
programmes et puis les régionales bien
entendu ce sont des élections qui sont
beaucoup plus favorables en général à la
représentation démocratique et donc à la
présence des écologistes puisque c'est
une élection à la proportionnelle avec
une prime majoritaire de 25 % mais c'est
quand même la proportionnelle qui
qui est majoritaire et la région un rôle
fondamental à jouer dans la lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique dans
l'amélioration des transports dans la
transition de l'agriculture est
aujourd'hui valérie pécresse à la région
ile de france applique une politique qui
l'héritière des politiques
d'urbanisation de développement
économique y réfléchit et du tout
croissance des réseaux n'est issu des
années 70 et 80
donc oui nous avons évidemment un rôle
fondamental à jouer dans ces élections
et nous serons bien entendu présent on
arrivait à la fin de cet entretien merci
david douillet d'être venu leur bateau
virtuellement dont je rappelle vous êtes
co secrétaire d'europe écologie les
verts d'île de france
on reste dans les municipales on en
parlait justement attrape la liste de
l'ex adjoint ali rabais l'a emporté
devant celle de l'élue d'opposition
othman nas roues et celle du maire
sortant guy malandain
ce dernier cède son fauteuil 19 ans
après son élection les détails avec reno
grégory canal et trappes aura bientôt un
nouveau maire dans ce second tour où
c'était une triangulaire qui était
proposé aux électeurs la liste conduite
par ralliera verts remporte le scrutin
est la gauche unie pour que tu rappes
respire soutenu par génération europe
ecologie les verts le parti communiste
et tout récemment le parti socialiste
totalise 40,4 % des votes
un grand sentiment de fierté parce que
les trappistes à plus de 40 % ont choisi
de porter la liste de la gauche unie
pour que tu rappes respire est un
également un sentiment de responsabilité
parce que je suis élu dans un contexte
particulier celui de la crise du corona
virus qui frappe encore notre pays et il
y a besoin ici plus qu'ailleurs de
solidarité de services publics
d'engagement de la part des
fonctionnaires de la part des
associations de la ville et nous
disposons ici de grande énergie de
grandes forces vives ma responsabilité
sera de les mobiliser
l'ancien adjoint et membre de la
majorité s'était présenté face à guy
malandain maire sortant en lice pour un
quatrième mandat
soutenu par la république en marche et
lâché entre les deux tours par le parti
socialiste est la tête de liste de pour
trappe la gauche qui agit se classe en
troisième position avec un score de 22
4%
élu en 2001 guy malandain passe donc la
main après dix neuf ans à la tête de la
municipalité et n'a pas décidé encore
s'il s'y
dans l'opposition je garde le souvenir
d'avoir fait d'avoir fait au mieux
rien n'est parfait il ya toujours des
choses à faire
je ne me vois pas passer le bâton du
relais de la course à pied comme ça à
quelqu'un qui que j'ai invité avec son
copain amont là que j'ai invité à venir
dans l'équipe pour terminer par une
trahison tout simplement
distancée de dix points au premier tour
othman nasro lui arrive à la deuxième
place avec 37,18 % des suffrages mais
avec un écart qui s'est resserré
cent soixante et une voie entre sa liste
engagement trappe citoyens et celle
d'ali rabais en duo avec mustapha
larbaoui pour le scrutin il envisage de
déposer un recours suite aux résultats
de ce second tour
nous avons fait nous le chemin que nous
devions faire pour proposer votre appli
une autre alternative que l'élection de
monsieur rabais parce que je considère
que ce serait totalement catastrophique
pour trappe
je le dis j'en parle au conditionnel
puisque on regarde des conditions dans
lesquelles s'est déroulé ce scrutin au
regard des attaques personnelles des
méthodes qui ont été employés nous
envisageons de déposer un recours
à noter que la participation est en
hausse à trappes 38,25 % soit 4 points
en plus par rapport au premier tour
conseils d'installation prévue ce
vendredi 3 juillet à 19 heures en mairie
la commune de la verrière a basculé à
droite une perte historique pour la
gauche cette commune bastion communiste
depuis 1977
nicolas dainville a remporté ce second
tour avec plus de 47% des voix devançant
la maire sortant pcf névés duthu nicolas
landry
c'est un scrutin historique pour la
commune de la verrière un basculement à
droite pour cette ville communiste
depuis 1977
le candidat divers droite nicolas
dainville remporte ces élections
municipales 2020 avec 47 52 % des
suffrages
une victoire de justesse avec 58 voix
d'avancé sur nelly duthu grande joie une
grande responsabilité
un grand honneur on a envie avec
l'équipe de faire des belles choses pour
cette ville de la verrière de lui à
impulser une nouvelle dynamique et et
c'est très important qu'on se mette au
travail dès demain pour agir sur
l'emploi sur l'éducation sur la sécurité
sur le cadre de vie dans cette
triangulaire du second tour la gauche
partait divisée
d'un côté la maire sortante communiste
nelly duthu élu en 2007 suite à la
démission d'alain ajaj de l'autre jean
yves blé son premier adjoint qui en 2019
créer un groupe au sein de la majorité
avec plusieurs élus sur fond de
désaccords unis dans ce scrutin la
gauche aurait pu l'emporter
dommage peut être qu'ils aient division
à gauche chez qui je pense que si on
additionne le premier tour les les voix
de monsieur blé les miennes on passe au
premier tour ok un petit peu compliqué
cette division mais bon voilà je suis
pas sûr que les mesures que vont prendre
le dessus d'un guide soit dans l'intérêt
des derniers rois donc à chaque fois que
les interactions menacé mais c'est david
va nous trouver sur la sur sa route
on a plus d'une fois essayé de tendre la
main à l'âme du cul madame ne l'a jamais
rendu finalement je crois que la rupture
peut être elle s'opère au départ de
monsieur hajjaj finalement on a
constitué une équipe là prêts à être à
l'écouté de monsieur dainville et à
attendre
lui qui nous écoutent également le
conseil municipal d'installation de la
verrière aura lieu ce samedi 4 juillet à
10 heures au centre culturel du scarabée
nouveau maire également du côté de
mantes la ville sammy damerdji a été élu
avec 55 points 85 % des voix avec une
liste sans étiquette l'union pour mantes
la ville dans ce scrutin où deux listes
qualifier au second tour se sont retirés
il devance le maire sortant cyril notre
qui totalise 44 15 % des suffrages avec
rassemblement pour mantes la ville
le rassemblement national perd donc sa
seule commune en ile de france conquise
lors du scrutin de 2014
écoutez les réactions des candidats
celle du vainqueur sami damerdji et puis
du maire sortant battu cyril note jeu
très heureux parce que c'est une liste
citoyenne il remporta sera son dernier
nationale une liste qui a été aidé par
aucun parti sur lesquels aussi le report
de voix est mitigé des partis qui
étaient de gauche qui se sont retirés
donc c'est vraiment une liste qui mérite
cette victoire à elle seule j'espérais
que l'éventuel report des voix de gauche
ne soit pas aussi important
malheureusement pour moi en tout cas
cela a été le cas et il n'y a pas eu de
surcroît de mobilisation des
abstentionnistes du premier tour et à
peine 2 % de plus de participation ce
qui est assez faible le duel tout le
monde le savait c'était la configuration
la moins favorable pour moi c'est de
désistement effectivement on s'en doute
provoqué 7 7 défaites dans une
triangulaire je pense que j'aurais eu
j'aurais mes chances pour pour
l'emporter
autre réaction à vous proposer sur ce
résultat de mantes-la-ville celles de
responsables politiques du département
la déléguée du rassemblement national
dans les yvelines mathilde de andrew et
et celle du président du département
pierre bédier qui s'est impliqué
personnellement dans la campagne en
appelant à voter pour samy damerdji
créer la dynamique donc
tout est bien qui finit bien une
construction collective et pour un
récapitulatif complet de ces élections
municipales n'hésitez pas à re voir
notre édition spéciale du lundi 29 juin
en replay sur notre site internet vous
pouvez également retrouver le club de la
presse ce week-end qui revient avec pour
invités aurore bergé
on ferme cette page politique et on
passe au reste de l'actualité
la première phase du nettoyage de la
décharge sauvage à carrières sous poissy
a commencé en janvier dernier toutes les
parties prenantes de cette opération ou
fait un point sur la situation lundi
patrick jacques de dixmude et nicolas
d'andré opération nettoyage de la
décharge sauvage de carrières sous
poissy une première phase lancée au mois
de janvier 2020 avec déjà 65 % de l'âme
à collecter spécialisée dans le
recyclage des matériaux l'entreprise
biche et à filiale du groupe colas est
chargé de trier et valoriser les déchets
notamment avec cette plateforme de tri
dans la plaine on va effectuer un
premier tri ce qui va nous permettre de
séparer les gros éléments
donc tout ce qui est là qui va pas
pouvoir être valorisé la partie 30,80
donc c'est ce tapis là sur lequel on a
installé un aspirateur donc qui va
inspirer les éléments légers ensuite le
reste pas sur le tapis centrale tombe
dans le banc de tri donc à l'intérieur
de la cabine un tapis principal quatre
personnes qui sont en fin de 2e et deux
de chaque côté et qui vont trier le
département a sélectionné trois
entreprises dans le cadre de cette
opération avec une mission de
surveillance et de pose de clôture pour
protéger cet espace un investissement
d'1 5 million d'euros de l'état et du
conseil départemental
vous avez là la démonstration que quand
la ja coordination les volontés de la
part des acteurs publics lorsqu'il y met
les moyens
ben ils arrivent à des résultats
spectaculaires nous voulions voir le
résultat du travail collectif de dealers
acteurs publics et privés je parle des
entreprises et acteurs publics ses
pensées départementale communauté
urbaine l'epamsa qui est
dispendieux de l'état je le rappelle est
l'état dans ce travers le président a
prononcé le chiffre de huit cent mille
euros que nous devons l'engagement du
préfet de région ile de france
une deuxième phase de nettoyage va être
lancée au mois d'août 2020 objectif
dépolluer 75% de la plaine de déchets
d'ici à la fin de l'année un projet
d'aménagement d'un espace naturel
protégé en cours de réflexion est prévu
une fois la dépollution terminé une
opération tout de même freiné par la
découverte 900 tonnes d'amiante
obligeant les équipes à réorganiser
l'espace pour sécuriser le périmètre 600
tonnes du matériau toxique ont déjà été
évacués par une entreprise spécialisée
les vacances scolaires débutent ce
vendredi et dès mercredi nous nous
posions la question où vont partir les
yvelinois mélanie poké et mathilde et
demi et y ont répondu
[Musique]
cette saint-quentinoise programme ses
prochaines vacances
un voyage plus tôt en octobre mais
surtout s'en sortir de l'europe
on voyage pas mal surtout mon mari mais
je connais pas budapest est ce un rêve
y aller depuis très longtemps c'est un
projet qu'on a depuis depuis deux ans et
on aimerait bien bien le faire dans
cette agence à nîmes antennes les
demandes ont été réduites
emmanuel van un voyage par jour à la
même époque l'année dernière deux à
trois séjours étaient réservées
quotidiennement et pour l'été la
tendance va plutôt à l'hexagone
beaucoup nous disent ben je veux pas
partir en dehors de la france parce que
si jamais on doit être confiné
on veut pas être confinée à destination
de 2,2 en plus d'avoir à payer les frais
que ça engendre est resté bloqué dans un
pays étranger
le mali
mali pour l'instant on ne peut pas y
aller un voyage hors d'europe encore
compliquer dès le 1er juillet les
français peuvent se déplacer en dehors
de l'union européenne à condition que
l'épidémie soit maîtrisé dans le pays
souhaitait pour cette agence
versaillaise 150 voyages ont été annulés
depuis le confinement
même là des gens qui devaient partir le
3g gens d'avoir une annulation de vol
pour la guadeloupe donc vraiment on n'a
aucune certitude et c'est ça qui est le
plus long à dire le plus compliqué ce
qu'on ne peut pas les rassurer il son
jeu ça se comprend qu'ils sont ils ont
envie de partir mais nous on n'a pas
plus d'informations
m selon les entreprises du voyage cette
année 87 % des français projette de
partir en vacances en france et 13% à
l'étranger lors des années précédentes
ils étaient plus de 30% à quitter
l'hexagone
mercredi soir c'était l'un des premiers
rendez-vous d'athlétisme en france post
déconfinement le club local de
versailles a organisé un grand meeting
réunissant près de 200 sportifs en
obtenant les autorisations à la dernière
minute
un reportage de michael et demi d'euros
les organismes ont souffert pour cette
reprise mais les sourires étaient sur
toutes les lèvres après plusieurs mois
d'attentes l'union athlétique de
versailles a organisé ce mercredi 1er
juillet l'un des tout premiers meetings
d'athlétisme en france post confinement
au total 200 sportifs venu des yvelines
et de la région répondu présent à un
retour à la piste énorme c'est cool
premier sentier de toute la saison
ça pique ça fait un peu mal au genou
mais le retour à la piscine normes je
trouve ça fait du bien ça fait du bien
de reprendre les compétitions parce que
on avait repris les entraînement nez
l'esprit de compétition
ça me manquait un peu l'esprit de
compétition innovation et où il ya du
monde et plus et on voit le résultat de
les entraîner l'entraînement le
rendez-vous a été validé la toute
dernière minute par les instances
l'autorisation finale a été donné à 13
heures le jour même les organisateurs
ont dû répondre au contexte sanitaire du
moment fallait respecter les gestes
barrière avoir les autorisations de la
préfecture de la ville de versailles de
la direction départementale de la
cohésion sociale
donc ça a été un véritable parcours en a
limité le meeting à 200 personnes
environ pour éviter qu'il y ait trop de
monde sur le stade et en respectant à
tout un parcours pour rentrer sur le
stade et sortir du stade le club
d'athlétisme espère maintenant pouvoir
organiser d'autres meetings d'ici la fin
de l'année 2020 une compétition de lance
est notamment à l'étude
50 propositions pour une nouvelle
génération de la décentralisation
elles ont été remises jeudi à emmanuel
macron par le président du sénat et
sénateur des yvelines gérard larcher
elles sont le fruit d'un groupe de
travail de parlementaires issus de tous
les groupes politiques du sénat
l'objectif replacer les collectivités
territoriales au centre du pays
les propositions préconise plus de
souplesse d'autonomie et de pouvoir de
décision aux régions départements et mer
moins de discours plus de proximité a
même demandé gérard larcher dans une
conférence de presse
écoutez ce que nous disait à ce propos
sophie primas sénatrice des yvelines dès
dimanche soir lors de notre direct
spécial pour la soirée électorale
le sénat dans les jours qui viennent et
par la voix évidemment de son président
qui est yvelinois gérard larcher nous
allons présenter un plan de
décentralisation déconcentration de
l'état nous pensons vraiment que c'est
une des leçons de la crise du coc vide
mais c'est une des leçons sur laquelle
nous travaillons depuis longtemps depuis
la crise des gilets jaunes sent bien que
cette notion de proximité cette notion
de capacité à répondre de façon plus
proche sur le terrain est plus agile et
plus réactive et plus facile est un des
éléments de la de la route de de la
restructuration de notre paysage
politique donc dès la semaine prochaine
dans les jours qui viennent gérard
larcher y fera une proposition président
de la
public sur une proposition de loi sur la
décentralisation et la déconcentration
des taxes mais je pense un élément
majeur pour la suite pour votre rubrique
ça s'est passé nous partons en décembre
2002 le mois durant lequel le sida
devient une pandémie apparue au début
des années 80 la maladie touche plus de
26 millions de personnes dans le monde
en 2000
[Musique]
ce dimanche 1er décembre avait lieu la
15e journée mondiale de lutte contre le
sida
quinze années de lutte contre le virus
de l'immunodéficience humaine qui tue
encore selon l'institut national de
veille sanitaire l'île de france est une
des régions française la plus touchée en
2001 2,3 cas était décelée pour 1000
habitants
je me rends compte que la maladie qu'on
croyait
on voit deux
non pas de disparition bien entendu mais
de diminution est en train de prendre un
nouvel essor sur les yvelines selon li
nvs entre le 1er avril 2001 et le 31
mars 2002 21 cas de sida ont été
notifiés ce qui porte à 1159 cas cumulés
depuis 1978
le centre de dépistage anonyme et
gratuit implantée à l'institut de
promotion de la santé à trappes depuis
janvier 2002 a déjà accueilli 460
personnes à la fin du mois d'octobre
si la population venant faire le test
est plutôt hétéroclite les médecins
observent une présence accrue des jeunes
les rapports entre eux sont extrêmement
fréquents
il y à peu je dirais de gens qui ont des
relations suivies avec le même cas même
personne la jeunesse
je dirais
qui à 20 ans à l'heure actuelle c'est
essentiellement elle qui a oublié qu'il
fallait faire attention
le profil des populations contaminées
évoluent les personnes hétérosexuelles
sont aujourd'hui davantage touchés
d'autre part certaines communautés sont
particulièrement exposés un des
principal foyer d'infection aujourd'hui
c'est l'afrique subsaharienne
donc il ya une vraie réalité de
l'épidémie dans cette communauté l'a
donc ce que comme si vous disais tout à
l'heure c'était d'abord de changer
le déni dans cette communauté en fierté
de ce mobile à entier de ce mobile de se
mobiliser
l'association aide s'est installée ali
ps depuis le mois d'octobre dernier pour
se rapprocher des populations à risque
souvent en situation de précarité
si la baisse de vigilance est
aujourd'hui l'une des causes de la
progression de la maladie en france
l'accès généralisé aux traitements
thérapeutiques y participe largement la
quadrithérapie et la trithérapie on va
le dire dans ce sens là sont des
traitements qui ne soigne pas ne sont
pas curatif pour la maladie mais qui
essentiellement retarde l'apparition de
cette maladie
ces traitements des effets secondaires
lourds les gens n'ont pas forcément
conscience
il est donc important de rappeler que la
prévention est la meilleure des
solutions
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis retrouvez votre
actualité locale dès lundi avec le 7-8
journal bon week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or
[Musique]